the cdc is now recommending the pfizer
vaccine for children ages 5 to 11. what
does that mean what are the benefits
what are the drawbacks and how you can
help in the battle against
misinformation with our good friend the
surgeon general dr vivek morthy let's
get started
we have a lot to talk about yes a lot's
happened since you and i last chat yeah
now we have the vaccine that is more
widely available for kids and that's a
topic i really want to dive into but
first let's talk about this
misinformation toolkit that you've
published tell me more about that now we
did that not because health
misinformation is new but because in the
last few years we've seen a dramatic
increase in the scale and the speed and
sophistication with which this
misinformation is spreading so we wanted
to call attention to that and let
everyone know that there were steps all
of us could and needed to take and
here's why this is so important because
there's a recent poll that just came out
that showed that close to 80 percent of
people
either believe or think some of the
myths out there about clovid19 are
actually true what i love about the
approach that's really highlighted in
this toolkit is that you want to lead
with an empathetic approach you want to
be not so much challenging what people
currently believe but sort of coming
from a place of understanding of where
they're hearing it why they're worried
one of the things that you know we
advocate for in this toolkit is first
just taking a pause to understand what
people's motivations are what their
concerns are what's important to them if
we don't take an empathetic approach if
we don't give people the benefit of the
doubt before we judge or shame them then
we lose them you know we don't have the
opportunity to to support folks in
reaching that shared goal you know i
haven't heard of a single person's mind
who's been changed by being shamed or
blamed
so the bottom line is those approaches
don't work yeah tell me uh what vaccine
has been authorized by the fda under the
eua and what are the steps that parents
should take to getting this vaccine for
their kids well i'm glad we're talking
about this because this is a landmark
moment uh for not just for parents like
me about kids 5-11 but for all of us who
want to see this pandemic come to an end
with the recent fda authorization and
the cdc recommendation of the vaccine
for kids five through eleven and this is
the fizer vaccine mind you we now have
28 million
children 28 million more people who have
come under the umbrella potentially of
being vaccinated but here's what parents
really need to know number one the
vaccine was rigorously tested in
clinical trials and it was put through
the same review process by the fda and
cdc that we put any other vaccine
through and what they found in that
review process was that this vaccine was
highly effective more than 90 percent
effective at protecting our kids from
symptomatic covet the second thing they
found is that the safety profile of the
vaccine was actually really really good
and when children did have a side
effects they were a sore arm fatigue a
headache occasionally a fever but those
symptoms went away within a day or two
and what the children were left with was
longer term protection and very
importantly they did not see any serious
adverse effects do you view this
authorization for five to eleven year
olds as a potential off-ramp for some of
the residual mass mandates that still
exist whether it's in schools in
hospitals yeah well so i think the more
people get vaccinated the more we have a
chance of getting cases that come down
and stay down and that's really going to
be our key to an off ramp with things
like masks and other restrictions as
well kids in addition to getting kovi 19
also can spread kovid19 there was a
notion out there before that kids don't
transmit the virus we absolutely found
that is not the case they do transmit
the virus they contribute to spread and
so yes getting 28 million more children
vaccinated will absolutely help reduce
the spread help get cases down keep them
down and that's how when we can start to
get rid of some of the restrictions that
we currently have right now how does
getting your child vaccinated protect
grandma well great question we know
again that children can transmit uh the
virus that has definitely been proven we
also know that when children then see
folks who are vulnerable like
grandparents for example especially
those who have not been vaccinated
there's a real risk they can pass on the
virus to them and that's important
because we've seen the vast majority of
deaths that have taken place in kobe 19
has occurred among the elderly
population those above 65. and finally
mike i think it's important that we
recognize one thing that covet has
taught us right is that
our health really does depend on what
other people do yeah right and what
we've learned from other viruses and
illnesses in the past is that more of us
get vaccinated the more of a wall we
build around those who are vulnerable
yeah and you know a very specific
question that i see come up quite often
on social media and for my patients is
on the topic of myocarditis the
inflammation of the heart we didn't even
see that in the the pfizer study uh for
five to eleven year olds do you think
the study had sufficient
participants to rule that out and if it
does happen what does it mean how does
it compare to getting myocarditis from
actual covid19 the trial that was done
for kids 5311 had several thousand
children in it right so they were able
to detect
side effects that would happen with any
reasonable frequency and thankfully they
didn't see any serious adverse effects
now is there a chance that there could
be a very rare side effect that crops up
and there's always
that chance but everything we do is a
risk benefit right and what we we have
to compare the risk of any vaccine to is
to the risk of getting coveted itself
and there what we do know is that people
who get covet do have a significantly
higher
risk of actually having cardiac
involvement like myocarditis we also
know that they have a risk of blood
clots they have a risk of long covet and
a whole host of other
issues which you don't see
with vaccines i think the reality of how
prevalent covet is now in our society
that
you're basically choosing between
getting the vaccine and getting covet at
this point because i don't think there's
a child out there who you can say they
probably won't experience covet i think
it's so prevalent that you're almost
having to make the choice it's between
the vaccine or covet and in that case if
you look at the myocardis that has
happened in the slightly age higher age
range for kids it's been so
few in comparison to
getting myocarditis from covet 19 you're
essentially making the decision between
one of two paths and we want to make the
the path of least disease least
infection least complications and
cova-19 has a lot of complications as
you said so i really that's like the
take-home point for parents how do you
see this misinformation playing out with
the topic of infertility for children
because that's something a lot of
parents are worried about because their
children five to eleven don't have that
issue at that point obviously
but then later in life is that something
you're concerned about even perhaps for
your own children yeah i'm glad you
raised it because there are about a
third of folks out there who either
believe or unsure about this myth around
infertility the truth is that there is
nothing in the the data that we have in
the science that lends any credence to
that rumor there is no link
between the vaccine and infertility and
that's actually why i'm getting my
five-year-old vaccinated too because of
course i want him to have a healthy
future i want to be healthy in all ways
i would love to him for him to have a
family one day uh if he wants to but i'm
not concerned that the vaccine is going
to inhibit any of that if anything i
feel the vaccine will give him a greater
shot of leading a healthier life and not
having complications from covet and
that's what we all want as parents
what's your guidance on receiving the
covet 19 vaccine for your 5 to 11 year
old uh and getting other vaccines at the
same time the good news is you can get
other vaccines as well it's very
important to get vaccinated for flu you
just need to get it at a different site
so you know we have two arms so we can
get a shot in each arm what would you
tell parents who have an 11 year old
who's close their 12th birthday should
they wait for the 30 microgram dose yeah
so i would say i would say don't wait
i'd say go ahead and get your dose now
and if your child is 11 they'll get 10
micrograms if they're 12 by the time
they're due for their second dose then
they'll get 30 micrograms you know at
that point but the reason not to wait is
that you don't want to delay your child
starting to build protection and they
will start to build protection with that
10 microgram dose especially with as
much covet as we have circulating the
faster kids get protected the better are
there any children uh that you would
recommend to not get vaccinated or hold
off waiting to get vaccinated so i'd say
the only reason to hold off
getting vaccinated is if you have a
specific allergy to a component of the
pfizer vaccine that's very rare
people generally don't don't have that
but if you have an allergy to foods or
to eggs for example other things you
don't need to
avoid getting vaccinated we want people
to go ahead and get vaccinated yeah i
think a lot of patients and parents have
questions if their child has a unique
condition whether it's a platelet
condition
some other allergy
perhaps a heart condition or diabetes
runs in the family and they get worried
if their child is at a higher risk to
having side effects is any of that true
well so you so generally we haven't seen
you know any concerns with with children
with other medical conditions getting
the vaccine that's good news in fact i
would say the flip is true which is if
you have other medical conditions then
we know from our experience with kova
that increases the risk of you having
bad outcomes if you get covet 19. so in
my mind it's actually all the more
important for children with other
medical conditions to get vaccinated to
protect them against the bad outcomes of
the virus one thing it's really
important i think is for us to recognize
that getting our kids vaccinated is also
about helping to address the profound
mental health tool that our kids have
sustained over the last 20 months rates
of anxiety and depression and loneliness
rise among many groups of children and
this is so sad to see and it's and it's
heartbreaking but we can do something
about it that's where the vaccine is so
helpful it's a very holistic approach
and as a family medicine doctor who's
also an osteopathic physician by
training i i very much appreciate you
thinking in those terms and i am so i'm
really hopeful also at this moment and i
know that you sometimes you read the
news and and it can feel like it's doom
and gloom all the time but there are so
many reasons at this particular point in
time to be hopeful we have not just one
but three vaccines available we have 190
million plus people have been fully
vaccinated we have our kids back in
school we have vaccines for kids 5-11
and we're finding ways to get back to
our way of life but we can only do it
together and that's why it's not just
about doctors like me and you having
conversations about people recognizing
the power they have because of their
voice because of their trusted
relationships they can be the person who
makes a difference in someone else's
decision to get protected by getting
vaccinated dr morty thank you so much
for educating us empowering us to help
my viewers and myself and my family to
make the right decisions about our
health and i hope we continue meeting up
with this misinformation we have a
toolkit now that i can arm my residents
with community leaders with and we
continue to thank you for the work that
you've been doing so thank you for that
i so appreciate that mike i had a
difficult patient encounter click here
to check that out and as always stay
happy and healthy
you